I heard a thing...
I heard on the grapevine that
your cherry remains unpopped
That's none of your business
I heard a rumour that his ex broke up
with him because he wouldn't finger
his bumhole
Okay!
I heard she bit Simon Furthassle on the
scrote and now it's all wonky
like a discount avocado
See those two over there?
The one on the right has never been
in a lesbian relationship before
She's terrified of her
girlfriend's vagina
- I heard it was Ruby's vagina!
- Thank you
Ruby's got big beef curtains!
[laughter]
Do you reckon his brain is so small
because his dick's so big?
- That's a myth
- No it's not
A friend of a friend saw it once. She
said it was the size of two Coke cans,
on on top of the other
Length and width
See her? She believes that flicking the
bean might make her clit drop off
She hates herself. But she just
can't stop wanking.
My current school is in administration
because the headmistress embezzled
our funds
She's on the run now, in Mexico, with
our Geography substitute, Mr Peabody
She says you're, you know, a sex pervert
Has he got worms or something,
has he given them to me?
I heard the Untouchables are coming
in a limousine
Oh my god, if I had a limousine, I would
totally have sex in it and film it
Apparently there's been an outbreak
of pubic lice
[laughter]
Yeah he's definitely giving everyone
pubic lice
She's in there.
Gag reflex problems.
She vommed on her
boyfriend's penis
Scandalous!